i think it's so much more approachable
for viewers and people who watch us and
especially people in the industry to
admit like hey at one point i you know i
did pirate but i
i even now i still pirate what's
important is the word did yeah right
yeah it's that you did pirate but you
don't actively
yeah i only rely on pirating now if i
have a choice to pay and get it done
easily i will yes i'm lazy and that's
what i'll do but yeah
you know i think having this mindset of
you can never admit that you pirated you
can never speak no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
no has any merits like i feel like it
just actively pushes people away from
having any form of constructive like
argument yeah because i think i think in
in
i think actually most people would fit
somewhere in the middle i think so i
think but the only takes we see on
twitter
is either like people actively like
slut-shaming piracy or something like
that
or just ordering on pirates or
neither of these are correct and i don't
know why these are the only takes i see
on twitter
i think as well one thing that drives a
lot of people away
especially from the the bigger figures
like the a lot of the voice actors and
all the people in the industry is that
like just actively like saying like you
know you are wrong i am in this industry
i know better than you
although okay there is a sense of that
right you are in the industry so maybe
you have a
bit more of a point but you know as far
as a voice actor goes it's like
you have no [ __ ] saying what happens
you're you're doing a job like you're
doing a service like as far as you're
concerned you're just in the show and
that's where you're like
yeah commitments end you've no bearing
on the shirt yeah you're not in the
industry oh no right right and
i think you know it's it's i think that
a lot of these voice actors are also
forced then to like you can't because
the way the industry works you can't
like you can't be
to your friend no you're wrong because
if your scene is problematic like no
it's serious like if you're saying it's
problematic it's like oh well maybe a
director won't hire you because
you're you're being a bit of a dick on
twitter right right you don't support
you said anime piracy was uh good and we
you know we wanted to hire you but yeah
you know
i mean i mean i i think a lot of people
don't realize that just actively shaming
people
and like it's just we'll just push them
away to the other side
and it doesn't work by saying hey you
you know you shouldn't pirate this is a
bad thing even though like
technically you know it is you know yeah
but that you know
that doesn't mean that people don't buy
it for like a reason yeah
as weird as it is to say it's like a
really weird form of gatekeeping almost
you know it's almost like a reverse
gatekeeping where it's like
if you if you pirate then you're not a
real anime fan you really don't support
the industry and it's like
no you you can you can eventually get to
that point but you have to
start somewhere right yeah and if piracy
is your only option
then piracy is your only option yes i
saw like it was like a tweet i don't
know it was one of the takes that was
like oh it's not available in your
country tough it wasn't made for you and
it's like whoa
it's like yeah okay no one has right to
anything right but yeah
also if you can't get it legally and
you're a fan of the stuff like yeah [ __ ]
it
who cares pirate that [ __ ] there's no
way for you to pay for it like what
why why i don't understand why this is
such a no you can't there was another
[ __ ] horrible take which was like
anime is a luxury you remember that one
oh yeah yeah we saw like this like list
of [ __ ] like
horrible arguments towards piracy it was
like anime is a luxury and you you
should be
you should you should really like you
know be proven lucky that you even get
the chance to watch any of this stuff
i'm like yeah it's just a [ __ ]
cartoon bravo
i know some people who like work like
two jobs have no [ __ ] money
and like yeah they can't afford the like
three subscriptions they need to watch
all the shows they want
yeah dude kick back and relax you
deserve that [ __ ] you've been working
hard
man like i don't i don't give a [ __ ] i
would if someone is broke as [ __ ] i
would not shame them
no i don't care like i think that we can
all agree that the probably the worst
take is the the whole anime merch
take right oh god like the i buy anime
merch therefore i have the right
to pirate like we think we all buy a lot
of anime merch
yeah yeah used to right i used to buy a
lot
oh okay tell us the reason why yeah why
is that why is it a past tense
the real reason is
it's too much tea in this episode the
tea is being spilled
okay but like what are you as someone
who actually works in the industry
what do you feel about like that
argument of like the i buy anime merch
therefore
i have the right to pirate kind of i
mean you can't use it as a reason
because
i think i don't know how to explain this
like
for example royalties for goods so i've
heard from my
friends in the industry yeah they go to
different
departments it's not always directly to
like
that specific creator right yeah right
so so what so what are you saying like
if you buy if they buy merch
the money still doesn't go back to the
original creator it does it depends i
think
on the contract they had so i've heard
okay so i've heard
it's not i'm not in that i imagine the
bigger of a brand
the anime is the easier is to get a
better deal in terms of royalties and
cuts i imagine
yeah i don't know yeah because because
one thing that always like
that always confuses me is that people
think that i know
there's there's there's a lot of
arguments that that have been made that
doing x-word is better for supporting
the industry than doing why
and i don't know how much like i don't
know where they're getting this
information from because none of these
people are like working in the industry
so every argument i see on both sides of
things
is a lot a lot of the times just
anecdotal speculation
i'm just speculation there's no there's
no theory behind it they're just like oh
i mean i feel good
buying merch you know it feels like um
if i buy official merch right yeah
because it's tied to that particular ip
yeah you you just feel like oh i'm
supporting it i'm i'm helping to spread
the love i'm putting money into
something that's official
so therefore in the back of their head
they're just like yeah that's going to
go back to the creator in some way right
like they're not doing
anything right right yeah yeah yeah of
course but is it the best way to support
that particular creator of the ip no not
the best but better than